mientras finlandia y suecia reciben la
bienvenida a la otan rusia y china-
ahora se consideran una amenaza para la
misma así quedó definido en el nuevo
concepto estratégico que marcará la hoja
de ruta de la alianza para los próximos
10 años en una decisión militar
histórica que no se registraba desde la
guerra fría la organización acordó
reforzar el flanco oriental con 300.000
tropas de cara a la guerra rusa que
acedia ocra nia y los países miembros se
comprometieron a dar un paquete de apoyo
integral a largo plazo para que quieren
frente a la agresión de moscú
juntos estamos desplegando más activos
con todos nuestros socios en todos los
dominios por tierra aire agua virtual y
por el espacio estamos reafirmando que
nuestro compromiso es sagrado y el
ataque a uno de nosotros es un ataque a
todos y por eso defenderemos cada
centímetro del territorio de la otan
la región de lindo pacífico será la
nueva vía estratégica de la otan para
frenar ambiciones políticas económicas y
militares de china un país que ahora
representa un reto para los miembros de
la alianza en una zona geoestratégica
que incluso ya se habían planteado como
objetivo eeuu australia y reino unido-
con el pacto august en septiembre del
año pasado la colaboración en el indo
pacífico incluirá nuevas tecnologías
para la ciberdefensa seguridad marítima
y la lucha contra la desinformación
china está aumentando sustancialmente
sus fuerzas militares incluidas las
armas nucleares intimidando a sus
vecinos y amenazando a taiwán vigilando
y controlando a sus propios ciudadanos
mediante tecnología avanzada y
difundiendo mentiras y desinformación
rusa los jefes de estado y de gobierno
dejaron claro que la crisis económica y
alimentaria que afecta a varios países
no es acausa de las sanciones
occidentales sino por los bloqueos de
rusia a los puertos ucranianos y
aseguraron que aunque apoyan a ucrania y
cada centímetro del territorio de la
otan la alianza habilitarlo hace parte
del conflicto